you j'espère que vous allez bien il ya
un peu moins d'un an youtube a invité à
new york pour faire une mini conférence
devant d'autres créateurs youtube et je
leur ai parlé du lien entre l'ennui et
la créativité
alors cette mini conférences elle a été
diffusée sur la chaîne youtube créateur
academy mais je me suis que ça pourrait
vous intéresser
parce que c'était sujet qui voilà qui
touche tout le monde et notre motorisés
à l'arrêt ou peu d sur ma chaîne je les
doublés en français
donc voilà je voulais pas la publier
avant la vidéo que j'ai fait sur l'ennui
parce que sinon ça va pas trop de sens
là c'est un bon complément je trouve est
en tête d'autres compléments futures sur
l'ennui parce que c'est un sujet qui me
plaît voilà on verra je vous laisse
visionner la vidéo on se voit la semaine
prochaine loeb pis ciao
yo je m'appelle cyrus nov
un gratin français je parle de beaucoup
de choses sur ma chaîne mais surtout de
philosophie de plein de façons
différentes
il ya trois mois je lai à katmandou au
népal
je suis allée m'isoler pendant dix jours
dix jours de silence total du jour sans
internet 200 télévision son smartphone
sans livre son style aux sans papiers
c'est juste vous et votre esprit
c'est assez difficile c'est une guerre
contre soi même qu'entre ses pensées et
contre l'ennui et votre esprit veut
tellement s'échappe et que vous
commencez à voir des choses qui
n'existent pas par exemple quand je
regardais le mur je commence à voir des
lettres la cause des formes de la
peinture et du relief de la peinture sur
le mur quand je fermais les yeux je
voyais tout à coup des gifs de chat par
exemple ou bien une silhouette humaine
abstraites en train de marcher c'est
très étrange quand je regardais mon
corps je voyais un serpent enroulé
autour de moi qui ai essayé de me manger
et aussi étrange que cela puisse
paraître
c'était tellement réaliste ça en
devenait magnifique je veux ça deux fois
et à chaque fois ça m'a donné plein
d'idées pour ma chaîne mes émissions et
bien sûr pour ma vie alors est-ce que je
suis le seul à transformer l'ennui en
créativité
bien sûr que non le docteur sands iman a
mené une expérience elle a pris 40
personnes elle leur a demandé une tâche
très stimulante celle de copier les
téléphones d'un annuaire quoi de plus
ennuyeux et ensuite à leur a demandé de
jouer avec deux gobelets en polystyrène
et imaginé différentes utilisations l
amant dakar entre autres personnes de
juste jouer avec le gobelet donc ça
c'est la partie créative elle a
découvert que ce qui avait d'abord
effectuer la tâche ennuyeuse et est plus
créatif
le fait que l'ennui soit facteur de
créativité c'est quelque chose qu'on
sait depuis des siècles kierkegaard
c'est un philosophe danois du 19e siècle
il a cette citation que j'aime beaucoup
les dieux s'ennuyait donc ils ont créé
les êtres humains et le fait que la
créativité ça un remix c'est quelque
chose qu'on sait tous en gros on part
deux idées et on les fusionne où on tire
une idée d'une autre on associe def
on soustrait et pour ça il faut jouer
avec l'idée et ça ça nécessite du temps
si vous voulez jouer avec votre idée
vous vous ennuyez g li nan c'est le
créateur de haïti claude je passais
aucun c'est la série ça c'est l'un des
trucs qu'il a dit
j'utilise des programmes qui coupent
internet pour être obliger de m'ennuyer
car l'ennui est essentielle à l'écriture
avec internet il est désormais très
compliqué de se lier le processus
créatif nécessite des moments d'ennui de
blocage couper internet pouvait pas dire
ça des youtube heures peut-être que vous
devriez ces primes d'un travail notre
défi est de taille
en fait on doit suivre le rythme de
publication imposé par l'algorithme pour
améliorer notre visibilité et notre
nombre de vue notre exposition tout en
étant au coeur d'internet et de
l'industrie du divertissement se passer
d'internet semble hyper paradoxal et
pourtant c'est ce que je vous demande ce
que je vous demande ce que lundi
prochain
n'allumez pas votre smartphone ni votre
ordinateur pendant une heure après votre
réveil et vous serez peut-être surpris
n'ayez pas peur de vous ennuyer mais y
ait peur de devenir ennuyeux merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]